you might see someone that's killed
someone but
that was my friend
you understand we've starved together
we've gone through a lot together and
even though what they've done is very
wrong
you understand and man's not condoning
that and saying free the guys because
they killed someone no like this it's
not like that you understand but
generally that's my brother and that's
i've seen the innocence in my
hi i'm shine reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views that you know i'm saying
it's all good right now charm aren't ya
and i've had some bad dates how do you
think you've done on the date i don't
really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie
about it where are all the decent men
not in my dm's that's for sure you get
me i feel like i'm rolling with the man
then what's going on about your fives it
seems like a lot of men don't know how
to treat a lady i'll just manhandle
everything this guy's putting a chest
and chest in the nut like geez
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
i is the one and only brooks mackerel g
and um
i am here because i am here
well grill it who's going to be no one
bro what serious this is all about it's
not happening
what is this all hey that's great
it's good let's do it let's do it i'm
hungry too and i need some food yeah
let's go
hello hello you all right
good thank you what's your name
you don't know my name
hi hi you don't know my name
that's a bad stuff why should i know
your name it's blind date oh sir okay
it's backroad background yeah why
backwards
actually my friends gave me that name
you know
very [ __ ] bad
or a bad first impression still every
time they're with me i was able to like
maneuver and take them always on the
back roads of
without going on the main so yeah they
gave me that name stuff ah that's quite
calm yeah but what do women call you
br
g
so i would not be saying if i was in bed
with you i would not be saying vr like
no
how did we get there well cheers anyway
let's see
i don't like the way it's dressed
it's nice girls though
a nice watch
so backroads so you you say it's through
cut knowing to cut corners is it
anything to do with a certain lifestyle
um yeah yeah yeah no
yeah yeah or no yeah i know
yeah so yeah
yeah i know okay why yes and why no it's
just how my mentality was like i just
didn't really like
all that
attention on the main road you know i'm
saying especially if i'm walking and
people just driving and everyone could
just see me i didn't really like that
yes would you say you're like an
introvert
yeah you could say that what kind of
lifestyle do you have
or live
i live a very
simple lifestyle listen we all know
about these rappers lifestyles
i keep myself to myself still you know
i'm saying family oriented
so what makes you so family-oriented i
love my family man you get me yeah but
like loving them and doing things to
show that your family orientated are two
different things
and you really get the chance to like be
around all my family so like you know
i'm saying that the family thing i love
being around people that you know i'm
saying that got me and i got them too
you know i'm saying we do anything for
each other like what though
like anything what would you do for your
family um i look after them
if they need me to you know care for
them care for children
call them check on them
you know like put love and compassion
back into the home exactly
okay would you say your provider
yes for certain people yes okay why
aren't you certain people
because i can't provide for everyone i'm
not rich i'm working though i'm getting
there when i get there everyone's good
how many women do you entertain
none none i'm too busy so you're not
talking to any women no really too busy
right now too busy it's too much it's
too much so when was the last time you
had sex
boys he asked me that man it's crazy
business man i'm telling you no sir
no comment why not comment
no comment
so it's been recent then
no no not active like that no man i've
been working man i've been working on
something i can't really be talking
about like that for the last three
months i haven't even had me time i need
to go yeah treat myself and yeah i have
a little [ __ ] daily and i mean little
smoky i haven't even had time for that
ah so what does me time involve what do
you do i like to yeah cook for myself
put my feet up you know watch some some
series okay yeah so tell me about your
lifestyle so you just the homebody then
that's what you're explaining yeah i'm
basically a homebody man i come out when
i need to i just come out studio
work you know what i mean all the it i
find it hard to believe that you just
work go studio why i don't know why i
just i find it and i don't i'm not
trying to be rude but i find like most
men they have options and they do you
know they're not just like chilling what
type of options women
why does everything have to revolve
around women do you like female company
yeah a hundred percent i would i've got
a lot of female friends that call that
you get me so you actually have female
friends and you don't have sex with them
yeah
so how many days have you been on now
um enough
what's enough enough there's i've been
on quite a fair few
wow so how come you haven't found
the one what's stopping you joy is i
realize like i'm very particular about
what i want
just i'm not finding it i'm just not
getting a vibe men talk a lot of rubbish
to be honest with you suddenly women
yeah but it's like men will lie to your
face
like one thing women don't we don't
actually like your face
what in what in what planet
like men will like you'd like a man will
cheat and fully like lie yeah swear on
mothers and then turns out they actually
cheated like they'll create some back
road
that's some back road story i've done oh
watch this year when a guy cheats yeah
they don't really
i don't feel like they're invested in
the girl that they're cheating on like
you know what i'm saying
but if the choice is dead they would do
it in it you get it
but now a woman if a woman is cheating
on you she really like is interested in
this person that she's laying with you
understand and it's very scary because
you will never
never find out you look at me so pretty
like that and it's techie
i feel like you know i thought men cheat
a lot more than women do i'm not saying
women don't because they do but i feel
men cheat a lot more yeah i'll take the
silence really really some proof
we need some yeah we need to you need to
show me some statistics have you ever
cheated
um i need to think about this carefully
what do you mean think either yes or no
no no i have to think no no no i haven't
cheated definitely cheated
a little relationship i probably yeah
which you know i'm saying but they're
not wow i'm in the relationship no so
you haven't cheated but then have you
like
initiated conversations with other women
in order for you to like leave to then
go to the next woman no no no
that's like having a little plan no no
no no no we don't do that stuff though
that's
good now we don't believe that that's
really good
so did you say you're an artist yeah do
you get a lot of dm's from women
i get a lot of dm's in general
the way she looked over here i'm done
when i go on my instagram like when i go
on apps here i actually know what i'm
going there for okay so like
did you entertain it if a woman's in
your dm is like hey slides in what are
you doing tonight i can come see
you know what you're crazy that can't
happen how do i know you're telling the
truth
i'm not very accessible as you think
like you can't just link me like that
you know i'm saying like obviously not
in a mad way but like yeah it's not
really like that it's for me like
do you think do you see it as maybe you
think you're above these women
no man no i'm not above no one i'm a
normal human being but i am a king
you'll get me i am greatness
but i'm not bad no no no i rate that
know your self-worth yeah i do rate that
what makes you so great then
because i'm me there is not enough of me
but what's so great about me it's just
me yeah but like what i love me
everything about me yeah but it's good
that you can like love yourself and hold
yourself to that like title but
i wouldn't look and be like yeah you're
great
no but like but i don't i don't like for
me greatness to value someone else and
see them as like well you're great you
need to be like wow like your energy the
way you talk the way you are with
situations and everything
that is me that's you yeah really
well it's for me it's not giving that
vibe but you're snatching your chair
you're just like smoking on a very very
relaxed man it was there's relax and
just being rude
yeah [ __ ] really nice issue
yeah
here's what he is why are you slouching
man's coming through with like that
david bummy like energy disgusting
but it's true like realistically like
this is supposed to be a date yeah and
you stay like half answered and just so
what do you want me to come and not be
me no just come come correct just know
that's correct i'm coming as me if you
can't
take me as me
then why are we here
no like listen i'm all for like just yet
take accept someone for who they are but
at the same time it's like know how to
deal and handle situations like when you
first meet someone you know like you
want to just
show them like that you're this nice guy
because this is like a first impression
and you just sat there
like
see and you find it funny
yeah because um you know what i find
funny
because i'm not going to change for a
while yeah okay but i understand that
and it's good that you say that but it's
it's not funny
this is fun
she's dangerous you know blood yeah
people are scared it's easy yeah but
yeah see her
[ __ ] you know
but i was so close to walking out but i
said you know what
professionally let's be professional
yeah
what do you do for fun
studio studio that's when i'm at my
happiest when i make music if you're
trying to impress someone that you're
really interested in like me trying to
impress someone yeah yeah okay what are
you doing because you're not impressing
me now
boy i'm already put off love it's all
right
i'm not i'm not a guy that plans stuff
in it like you know i'm saying i'm a guy
i like to go
with the moment
okay the moment's now what are you doing
well you've kind of upset me so like i i
don't like yeah i'm not really
you know what i'm saying you go show me
like you gotta be nice to me now you
gotta make my heart fly a little bit now
you know what i'm saying why would i
make your heart fly because
come with like no because this is you
want me to come here and i've been
working love i just come back from
france i come off the air at the
washington press late night yesterday
did you know what like actually is nicer
okay if that's the case
yeah so what you do you'd say do you
know what i'm really excited to be in
this day i'm a bit tired so please
excuse me if i'm just a bit chill today
you know sometimes you have to be a bit
ahead
why don't you do that because if you're
trying to actually impress someone and
get on with them i'm not trying to
impress no one i'm being i'm being
myself like if you're gonna take me for
me love like
you know what i'm saying we're already
on the wrong foot yeah we are you know
what i'm saying like you're very
beautiful but like love you like you
need to open your heart a little bit you
know i mean like you're not going to
find a man like this so someone coming
in it's disrespectful so this is the
thing boobs you're not going to find a
man like this you can't say to them
open your heart and the first thing
you're doing
baby girl baby girl you ain't going to
find him under this yeah why did i even
come back do stuff why
you told me
you need to be you need to be
you know what i'm saying listen i'm very
calm i'm a very intuitive person no
because you're very young like
interviewing like yeah
listen i'm trying to take a breather or
sip some wine and try you know what i
mean relax relax
am i being a bit mean
i actually definitely will find a man
like that i'll tell you that
what's a toxic trait i love too hard
look
that is not your toxic trait it is no
it's not it is no it's not love's too
hard it's definitely not that
you've not even shown me any love you
said i love you no but i'm saying if
you're a person it's a natural like
loving person yeah you're not going to
be no i'm not a natural loving person
once i
i take you in and i give you that love
this yeah so would you say you're a simp
what
hey break that down
i've heard people throwing around this
world but i don't know what it means
what does it mean like a man that's like
overly nice that goes a bit over the top
with things and it's like to a point
that you're actually embarrassing
yourself because the woman doesn't rate
you
no i do i look like a simple i'm not
even impressing you right now i said
love too hard yeah when i'm in love too
hard i mean like
no i mean like how can i explain it
what is that noise
like i love you like i'm invested in you
like you're my babes like you know what
i'm saying like that i want you around
all the time like you don't mean like i
love too hard needy clingy
not needy
nothing you have to be in there to
understand but definitely not simple but
i don't know all about that stuff there
you go
that's still
yeah i like sims it doesn't strike me as
a simp when was your last relationship
no comment
why not are you in a relationship now no
comment you're in a relationship no i'm
not but no comment it's not as business
yeah but boy it is if you're on a date
well
yeah that annoying noise you keep doing
yeah
do you do that when you're having sex
you don't i don't still
actually you know what no no you're
doing it no i was trying to see like
have i have i actually done that no i
have been still no no
a that's a man's sport you get me yes
yeah you're a sportsman
top scorer
i just feel like doggy's just not
creative
no
do you like materialistic things
no as you can see
nice girls oh thank you
what's the most expensive thing
you have bought yourself stick like when
you see a materialistic what do you mean
you have a nice watch and you have girls
okay yeah so i see that as materialistic
so i wanted to then ask you
what kind of women do you attract i
don't know you don't know are you
forward so do you ever attract women
that are for your lifestyle
well that's what women like
there's actually like don't go wrong
it's nice yeah but but i don't i don't
buy these things and say oh yeah
calum are gonna love this
no
i buy it because
i like it yeah of course you can
understand from young i always wanted
girls i used to look at the rappers and
say oh he's got diamonds in his mouth i
like that i want diamonds in my mouth so
when i made enough money to do that i
did it
yeah no good on you for doing that i
like that it's nice
yeah
going somewhere mom's up to him he's
smiling i feel like he actually likes it
do you not ever think that having grills
and having nice watches is gonna change
the certain caliber of women that
approach you no because that's not what
i'm doing it for so that's not much for
that what i'm saying is right so if
you're in a club right yeah and you've
got a nice watch on and you have grills
in your mouth yeah do you think you're
going to attract a certain type of woman
right that's going to be with you for
your lifestyle and then you're going to
sit and complain about it and be like
these women are this that and disregard
them
no do you know why i wouldn't get there
because yeah one yeah
when i'm wearing my stuff
i'm not going to the club
thinking or looking for women okay you
understand so i wouldn't even get to
that point where i'm with a girl that's
before my lifestyle and i complain about
it because i've gone to the club to
drink a juice shake
and go home okay
you get me
sometimes you gotta look nice for
yourself yeah i like that about it's not
about what i don't see me i don't give a
toss
what people think
or what people got to say okay because
at the end of the day what do you say
he's not going to pay my bills um have
you ever suffered mental health yes so
how did you deal with that
start to go through some dark nights
yeah dark nights dark days but you know
what we come over yeah it's not easy
process man yeah so so what influenced
that
to like the dark nights
his life really my life man you know
sometimes you can get into a
certain space in life where
you see things a little bit you know
yeah and yeah i was there so how did you
deal with that
not very well
but
i'm growing as a man
i'm grown as a person every day i'm
learning you know and i have good people
around me that's really good well cheers
to that
nine
hmm
yeah but do you like head yeah
well do i like receiving yes yes but you
don't give yeah if you're selfish in bed
sorry
sorry so yes you're not getting read
then
i'm sorry
it's always the way they like it done to
them but they don't want to do it
hard enough listen can you put your card
up
oh sorry
oh yo
let it go
everywhere yeah i'll farm yeah
no i shouldn't be doing that enough what
nothing
i will definitely fart around you
all right me boy
why oh yeah
make you evacuate the premises and do
over there why is it a big issue if a
woman farts
it's not still
it's not it's not it's it's natural
you fart but just looks not next to me
yeah because if it smells it's crazy
yeah no no no puppy no no farts no
yeah
why yes and why not
depends it depends on dex yeah okay
why no phenix what would they have to do
for you to not stay friends be a crazy
one okay what's crazy
there's no such thing as a crazy ex
they're only crazy because of your
actions that made them crazy so that no
woman's just crazy for no reason do you
know what that sounded like
don't say crazy yes so you even knew the
answer next time you're predictable
that's why because you're particularly
i'm not predictable okay yeah i'm gonna
wait for it no comment
yeah that wasn't gonna come
joel
usually i'd be like no
okay i'm not saying i'm having sex with
you now on the first date just so we're
clear do you think that would change the
way you see and value the woman
it's a yeah no no it's not a year it's
50 50 because if i can't tell that you
genuinely
feel the same way i feel
then i wouldn't think like that okay but
if i feel like you don't and yeah
then
yeah you sure because i thought that men
do say oh yeah
you know i don't know on the first can
you stop doing this men thing because
i'm not men i'm one man me i don't yeah
i don't yeah it's one man me yeah yes
thank you very much see that's true
sometimes yeah yeah this is what i said
i like this power thing i thought it's
nice and quite you got a bit more
attractive because you put me in my
place
how many girls do you sleep with in a
month i'll comment why
like i just you know what no no i'm
gonna i'm gonna comment you know what i
i'm not like that so yeah
she don't sleep with any women in a
month
he keeps saying we're not in court why
do you keep saying no comment
yeah perhaps like uh brother all these
questions uh man just hit them with the
no comment man i understand i don't
really have to let you know or get into
it too much and i mean from yeah
i ask a question like how do you like as
a man in your life
value women
without women there is no us
they gave me
i respect them i love them
fully on my heart you know i'm saying i
respect them you know i mean they go for
a lot and they do a lot you know i mean
so they're very highly in my books
that's good yeah i like that see that i
feel like the date's getting better
it is
okay there's some king qualities there
there's potential um what would you do
if
my ex was after you well that's his
problem okay but what are you doing
nothing
clearly
yeah so if he's not here now yeah moving
mad you're just sitting there
oh we'll go you'll walk out i'm not
going back to chill
so you're going to walk out yes
and go
yeah that's better what would you do if
i couldn't cook
then there's no relationship
huh
so you can't cook no
that's beside the point
how's it beside the point why don't you
learn to cook and actually cook for me
both we're both supposed to know how to
cook okay but you're saying there's no
relationship yeah there isn't why
because cronkite that's a bit of like a
perfect reason to not be with someone
that's not that's a big big deal for me
it's a big deal for you yeah why can't
you cook
so why is it such a big deal what my
kid's gonna eat
you're gonna be feeding my kids what
okay
okay
good point
wow what would you do if i didn't like
your lifestyle
i'd tell you get with it or get lost
what do you want to do
that we already like we're together and
i want you to you know i'm just not
happy with it
that my lifestyle is working it you know
what i'm saying
i don't like my lifestyle then
you get obviously i understand if like
oh it's like i'm not
part of me working and was doing other
things and all of that and you don't
like my lifestyle okay i get that you
know i mean trying to change as a man
and i get that but what if like
priorities change so we now have a child
together and i don't like your lifestyle
because it's your job do you are you not
going to then change
we'll find
i'll find i'll try to find a way to meet
you in the middle
okay
so there is compromise yeah yeah okay
what would you do if your family didn't
like me
don't make me have serious questions my
family don't like you there must be
something wrong with you
so do you really value your family's
opinion then yeah
but like if i like if i properly just
like love you like that then
it don't matter i might have to learn
the hard way in it you know it's the
hard way
however it ends up
and how long are we in our relationship
we're in love how long have we been in
love two years two years
no no no we're dead man i don't care man
we're doing it that's a long time that
means like we know each other
you do if i'd slept with one of your ops
in the past
that you just found out
should not be good okay you don't care
actually
up like someone just actually tried to
like
harm me yeah
me personally yeah you're rob yeah no i
wouldn't be able to trust you so yeah no
i wouldn't have personally why wouldn't
you trust me this was before i met you
yes still i wouldn't be able to trust
you
i always have something in the back of
my mind so no oh really
so you mentioned how you went to prison
did that change your outlook on life
100
yeah what changed
me me me and uh how i think a little bit
you know and how i carry myself
yeah
don't want to go back there yeah for you
guys though how was you
carrying yourself
um
i was very loud
yeah
i was writing a joke yeah okay yeah and
what did you just say free who
food guys free big guys free guys free
yeah but sometimes you know when people
like say that term so loosely free the
guys sometimes these men are actually
murderers and deserve to be inside
so i don't really like your friends
your friends
but
what about when people don't
live a good lifestyle and then every man
saying free the guys
you don't know what's going on in
people's life how did they get there
what is going through their everyday
life
for them to get to that space that they
could do something mad like that no of
course do you not think about that i'm a
very diplomatic person and i understand
i'm a very understanding person yeah i
also am aware that hurt people hurt
people but there's people that are
actually like murderers
who are killing people and my mom wants
to shout through the guys
that can't run because something needs
to stop somewhere
i hear you want that man you know what
i'm saying obviously
my friends are innocent i can't speak
for anyone else
when i say free guys i mean through my
people
you know the ones that deserve to be
free okay but then do you think as
you're an artist
but how this can be very confusing to
these young kids that are like 12 that
are just probably getting groomed to
this kind of lifestyle they're just
hearing everyone saying like are free
the guys so then they think that this
lifestyle is acceptable yeah
yeah i know
at the end of the day this is what we
see in it so we should be able to
express how we feel we understand
without it um
being turned into something else you
understand
obviously there's some people that's out
there that's
i wouldn't say weak minded but very easy
to fall into certain things yeah
and there's some people that that just
don't think about certain things you
understand what i push to the young
people
is always be your own person and don't
let everyone influence you just because
you see me doing it
doesn't mean it's okay
i'm not i'm not a role mod i'm not a
politician i'm not a role model like you
understand that i've come from struggle
and pain
and a lot of heartbreak
traumatizing moments you understand and
i'm expressing
my life and what i've been through
you understand
you might see someone that's killed
someone but
that was my friend
you understand we've starved together
we've gone through a lot together and
even though what they've done is very
wrong
you understand and man's not condoning
that and saying free the guys because
they killed someone no like this it's
not like that you understand but
generally that's my brother and that's
i've seen the innocence in mind
you understand something's gone very
wrong for a man to end up in that place
you understand that i just want people
to always take that and have that in the
back of the mind because people are
always quick to you know
oh this this that this this that this
this that but if you used to go and live
that person's life you wouldn't even be
able to even walk five minutes or do
anything
yeah but you don't think there's other
ways and this is the thing like we don't
need this is what people no but there is
but wait wait wait wait this is
see someone that's never been there yeah
it's very easy for you to speak and say
there's many options you understand have
you've nev have you ever been in a place
where you have no options yeah but it's
no
this is the thing and this is what makes
me kind of laugh and i don't respect
this lifestyle simply because firstly
there's a victim mentality right
and i know it's going to be triggered
for a lot of people but people need to
understand just because they're street
life it doesn't mean that other people
don't know struggle
no no but this is not no that's
definitely not working
i know you're not saying that but what
i'm trying to explain there's a victim
mindset a mentality to these people that
choose this lifestyle right i have
struggled in my life and i'm not here
for the pity party that i know struggle
more than anyone that's probably been on
road yeah but i found options
you see no no no no what gives you the
40 to say that now no no but what i'm
trying to say to you from my experience
and it's all everyone but now but you're
listening no one's no one's like trying
to like make you experience or anything
called like that but you cannot
i'm not okay fine you cannot see that
okay you
personally have been through anything
old man's been through you understand
but what i'm trying to say to you is
i've gone through an experience right
i've gone through traumatic experiences
just like everyone else's 100
i'm never going to pick up a knife i'm
never going to pick up a gun i'm never
going to
sit and preach something i'm not going
to condone all this violence so this is
what i'm trying to say i understand
there's a mentality and there's this or
whatever and you're being groomed by
elders i get it but sometimes it's like
there are other options and that's where
it gets frustrating because when you've
got music and you've got artists
promoting this kind of [ __ ] it's not
really fair because it's just trauma
breeds trauma so when you're preaching
i hear what you're saying but you can't
sit there and say art is
promoting this [ __ ] because one
that's my life you understand
you ain't live man's life and you can't
tell me me speaking my story is [ __ ]
no
no but like i'm speaking for everyone
else right now we're having yeah you
understand we're hyper hypothetically
speaking right now in it yeah you cannot
sit there and say that you understand
and you cannot sit there and say that
whatever you've been through is more
than this person you understand whatever
you've been through just remember
there's someone else going out there
worse than you you understand so always
keep that in mind but i'm saying so if
someone's going first to you why pick up
a knife why pick up this no
that's that's no no but listen you just
ask me a question let me answer
something
i get what you're trying to say and i
maybe i probably didn't articulate
myself well i don't mean it i think i've
struggled to hustle you should but what
i'm trying to explain me personally but
there's so many other struggles in the
world and and this is why it gets
difficult because it's kind of like
they're it's like kind of hopeless and i
understand opportunities and stuff it
might not seem like they're there but
they are there no they're not there
don't say that because listen
if i wasn't making music yeah and if i
didn't get the opportunity or meet the
people that i met here to get to this
place
i've lived a crazy life miss and people
out here live crazy lives
sometimes yeah you might be right inside
and
to a certain extent yeah there might be
other options you understand but you see
when you have your back against the wall
yeah sometimes you don't see nothing i
get it you get you wake up every day you
see the same thing see me before i
started doing this music thing properly
did you think i ever thought it was
possible for me to go fly on a plane did
you think i ever thought that i would be
seeing the world yeah no but you can and
this and this is no but this is what i'm
trying to show you no but listen listen
listen until someone come and showed me
that i can
i didn't know it was possible
i didn't even know that could happen
you understand what i'm trying to say to
you but this is what i'm saying so that
if i'm thinking like that if i'm
thinking like that now what about the
other people that's out there
that's going through much more work
this is what i'm saying they're like so
now obviously i understand where you're
coming from but like people need to stop
this thing of where you come with this
judgmental thing yeah because you're
only good
because you've conquered something and
and you're here like you had the options
that i don't have options but i'm saying
no no when you meet options i mean like
you see how you're saying choices you
understand you had choices that's why
you didn't go pick up the knife that's
why you didn't do that alive you
understand okay now there's some people
that wake up and see
that's their only option whether it's
very very wrong
like we're not condoning it like no
human being should be going up to harm
another human being you understand
but in this day in society like that's
this was programmed into it but it's
programmed because it's like we're sorry
we're going to go
healthy it's a healthy discussion
background
look
like i actually value everything that
you just said so don't think that i i'm
coming here like on a high horse or
anything oh never never
i think when i say things it's out of
like love because it's just like firstly
like the culture we need to do better
and do things so i just think i you care
you understand 100 might not you don't
even have to um go into it and explain
like that and i'll proper i'll probably
get where you're coming from no but
thank you for just
every time every time
have you enjoyed the day i actually have
still yeah the pink has brightened up my
day has it
yeah did you enjoy it i did
i did did you even though you didn't
join by outfit but yeah yeah not a few
things you irritated me you know the
slouch in
sorry and stuff but it's nice that you
you had a nice little balance come on
man we're steady yeah
yeah
oh cheers to
a nice day cheers
so shy how was your day
that's all right i've just been drained
no the date was very woosh it was very
good
ups and downs
merry-go-rounds
but we come out on top
yeah yeah no he handed it well i feel
like i like the fact that he put me in
my place a few times
i don't really feel like i got growth i
can't be grilled because you know
you can't cook me you know i mean yeah
but yeah man
what do you think how do you think i did
i
no i'll see him as a friend
no she's beautiful
but uh
i choose a little bit better why
well because he was slouchy slouching he
was rude he kept saying no comment and
i'm asking he's saying he's a great man
but i'm asking you show me how great you
are and all i get is no comment you're
not great
i don't know
bad news not going to be a turn
so let's think he was disrespectful he
was sat down he kept saying no comment
um the only positive that i got is that
he held himself well when i was glenn
him and he did put me in my place a few
times so
i'm gonna give him a 4.5
you